it is better to be feared than loved if
you cannot be both so you might agree
with this statement if you fancy
yourself a Machiavellian Italian
diplomat and niccolo machiavelli lived
over five centuries ago but if influence
among unscrupulous politicians reaches
into the modern age he is mostly known
for writing a book called the prince the
hands book that established him as the
father of modern political theory
through its teachings power is the
ultimate goal through any means
necessary
pakia Velia was born in Florence on May
the 3rd 1469 to bernardo de niccolò
machiavelli a lawyer and his wife
Bartolomeo to stefano Nellie he was the
oldest son of his parents with two elder
sisters and a younger brother
the Machiavelli family it was an
established middle-class family not
particularly affluent but they had means
Machiavelli was born during a tumultuous
time in history in which the Pope's
waged war against the Italian
city-states and political alliances
frequently changed leading to the swift
rise and fall of many short-lived
governments France Spain and the Holy
Roman Empire all battled for regional
control and influence he began his
elementary education at the age of seven
and studied grammar rhetoric as well as
Latin not much is known about
Machiavelli's young life aside from the
fact that he was well versed in the
ancient classics among these he highly
prized his copy of Livy's history of the
Roman Republic
[Music]
Machiavelli's first recorded involvement
in the volatile florentine political
scene occurred in 1498 when he helped
the political faction that deposed gira
lama Savonarola who is the then dominant
religious and political figure in
florence in the same year Machiavelli
was appointed to the second Chancery of
the Republic as Chancellor and Secretary
to the town of liberty and peace
sensitive government agency dealing
chiefly with warfare and foreign affairs
Machiavelli participated in both
domestic politics and in diplomatic
missions to foreign governments these
posts allowed him many opportunities
over the next 14 years which allowed him
to closely examine the inner workings of
government he also met many prominent
individuals among them Cesare Borgia who
furnished the young diplomats with the
major profile of leadership for the
Prince Machiavelli quickly gained
political prominence and influenced by
1502 he was a well-respected assistant
to the Republican head of state piero
solder Eenie in 1512 spanish forces
invaded Italy and the Florentine
political climate changed abruptly the
Medici family were the rulers of
Florence for centuries but in 1494 they
were exiled allowing for an autocratic
regime to seize control Machiavelli was
purged from office jailed and then
tortured for his well-known republican
sentiments he was also finally banished
to his country of residence in packs
inna Machiavelli spent this time
authoring the small body of political
writings that sealed his place in
history completed between 15 13 and 1517
discourses upon the first decade of T
Livius and the prints were not published
in cell after Machiavelli's death in
1531 and 1532 respectively around 1518
he turned from prose to drama in Lemann
dragula like the authors other writings
it is firmly predicated on an astute and
unsentimental awareness that human
nature is flawed and given to
self-centeredness the play was popular
with audiences throughout much of Italy
for several years
his next efforts a military treatise
published in 1521 and entitled libera
della arte della guerra the art of war
was the only historical or political
work published during the author's
lifetime
meanwhile Machiavelli had made
attempts to gain favor with the MIDI see
including dedicating the prints to
Lorenzo in 15-20 he was appointed
official historian of Florence and was
subsequently entrusted with minor
governmental duties his prodigious
history of Florence carefully dilutes
his Republican platform with the modeun
bias expected of him in 1525 Pope
Clements the seventh recognized his
achievements with a monetary Stepan's
two years later the midi sea where again
ousted and Machiavelli's hopes for
advancement under the revived republic
were frustrated this was because the new
governments were suspicious of his ties
to Vemma DC disheartened by his
country's internal strife Machiavelli
fell gravely ill and died a
disillusioned man his dream of an
operational Republic and realized
critics have found it ironic that the
fiercely Republican Machiavelli should
have written a handbook advising an
autocratic leader how best to acquire
and maintain power and security
Machiavelli was acutely aware however of
foreign threats to Italian autonomy and
thus deemed it necessary for a strong
Prince to Fort French and Spanish
hegemony
hence the prince was addressed to the
ruling MIDI see he believes that a
shrewd head of state exemplified by
bahia was essential to sublimating
self-interest to common welfare since
handbooks of conduct meeting monarchical
needs had become immensely popular by
the 1400s the external form of the
prince was neither startling nor
particularly remarkable to Machiavelli's
contemporaries yet from its initial
appearance the Prince proved no mere
manual of protocol nor for even that
matter of even conventional strategy in
its chapters Machiavelli delineated a
typology of sovereignties and the
deployment of available forces military
political or psychological to acquire
and retain them the prince is the first
political treatise to divorce statecraft
from ethics as Machiavelli wrote how one
lives is so far removed from how one
ought to live that he who abandons what
one does for one ought to do learns
rather his own ruin than his
preservation adding to his unflinching
realism the common Renaissance belief in
humanity's capacity for determining its
own destiny Machiavelli posited to
fundamentals necessary for effective
political leadership
virtue and
Fortuna vertie refers to the princes own
abilities ideally a combination of force
and cunning Fortuna to the unpredictable
influence of fortune in a significant
departure from previous political
thought the designs of Providence play
no part in Machiavelli scheme on issues
of leadership Heather team asked by
other political theorists in vague
diplomatic terms Machiavelli presented
his thesis in direct candid and often
passionate speech he employed easily
grasped metaphors and structured the
whole thing in an aphoristic vein which
lends it a compelling Authority
reaction to the prince was initially but
only briefly favorable with catherine de
medici said to have enthusiastically
included it among other of Machiavelli's
writings in the educational curriculum
of her children but within a short time
the book fell into widespread disfavor
becoming viewed as a handbook for
atheistic tyranny the Prince sent
Machiavelli's other writings as well
were placed in the papal index of
prohibited books in 1559 the prince was
also held responsible for French
political corruption and for widespread
contribution to any number of political
and moral vices gentle A's
interpretation of the princes advocating
stagecraft by ruthlessness and a moral
duplicity was disseminated throughout
Britain through the works of such
popular and highly influential
dramatists as William Shakespeare and
Christopher Marlowe in the prologue to
Marlowe's the Jew of Malta from 1589
Machiavelli addresses the audience at
length at one point encapsulating the
Elizabethan perception of Machiavelli by
saying I count religion that a childish
toy and hold there is no sin but
ignorance here and in the works of
Marlowe's contemporaries Machiavelli was
depicted as an agent of all the
Protestant England despised in Catholic
high Renaissance Italy hostile English
interpreters so effectively typifies
Machiavelli as an amalgam of various
evils that the term Machiavellian is
still used today
rarely until the 19th century did
mention of the prince solicit anything
other than unfounded and largely
unexamined repugnance as Freddie Chia
Pelle has absolutely summarized
centuries had to elapse before the
distinction between moral moments and
political moments between technical
approach and moralistic generalities and
even between the subject-matter of the
book and the author's person were
finally achieved modern critics noting
these crucial distinctions have engaged
in a prolonged and animated discussion
concerning Machiavelli's true intent in
the prince an anomalous 17th century
commentator philosopher Pierre Bayle
found it strange that there are so many
people who believe that machiavel
teaches Prince's dangerous politics for
on the contrary princes
taught machiavel what he has written
since veils time further analysis is
prompted to the most prolonged and
animated discussion relating to the work
the true intent of its creator was the
treatise as Bale suggested a faithful
representation of princely conduct which
might justifiably incriminated subjects
that not its chronicler or had
Machiavelli in his manner of
presentation devised the volume as a
vehicle for his own commentary still
more calculatedly had the author
superseded description in a bleep
providing a legacy for despots a single
conclusion concerning the author's
motive has not been drawn though
patterns of conjecture have certainly
appeared within Machiavelli's critical
heritage Lord Macaulay and emphasizing
the writers Republican zeal and those
privations he suffered in its behalf has
contended that it is inconceivable that
the martyr of freedom should have design
Italy acted as the apostle of tyranny
and the peculiar immorality which has
rendered the prince unpopular belonged
rather to the age than to the man others
have echoed this suggestion examining
the work in its historical context john
Addington simons has deemed it simply a
handbook of Princecraft as that art was
commonly received in italy where the
principles of public morality had been
translated into terms of material
aggrandizement glory gain and greatness
many have urged that Machiavelli
intended the treatise as a veiled
satiric attack on the methods of Italian
tyranny or by obtrusive converse
according to Harold J Lasky the prince
is a text book for the house of Medici
set out in the terms their own history
would make them appreciated and set out
that its author might hope for their
realization of his insights into the
business of government while ultimately
unable to agree on the underlying
purpose of the prince nearly all critics
have nonetheless been persuaded of it's
masterful composition even when
unwilling to endorse its principles
Macaulay as affirms that the judicious
and candid mind of Machiavelli
shows itself in his luminous manly and
polished language and France s code to
Sanctus has determined that where he was
quite unconscious to form he was a
master of form without looking for
Italian prose he found it
sheer volume and intensity studies of
the prince
have far exceeded those directed a
Machiavelli's discourses however the
latter work has been acknowledged as an
essential companion piece to the format
all of the author's subsequent studies
treating history political science and
military theory stem from this
dissertation that contains the most
original thought of Machiavelli less
flamboyant than the prince and narrower
in its margin for interpretation the
discourses contains Machiavelli's
undisguised admiration for ancient
governmental forms and his most elegant
thoroughly explicated republicanism
commentators have noted the presence of
a gravity and skillful rhetoric that at
times punctuated the prince but are in
full evidence only in that works final
chapter a memorable exhortation to the
midi sees to resist foreign tyranny the
discourses also presents that methodical
extrapolation of political theory from
historical documentation which is
intermittent in the prince max Lerner
has observed that if the prince is great
because it gives us the grammar of power
for a government the discourses are
great because they give us the
philosophy of organic unity not in a
government but in a state and the
conditions under which alone a culture
can survive it has been deemed not at
all in Congress that an intellect
immersed in historical circumstance and
political impetus should so naturally
embrace comedy as well for Machiavelli
regarded comedy exactly as he conceived
history and interplay of forces leading
unavoidably to a given result
Machiavelli's man dragula is only work
in the comedic genre clearly reflected
this parallel the Sanctus has remarked
that under the frivolous surface of man
dragula are hidden the profoundest
complexities of the inner life and the
action is propelled by spiritual forces
as inevitable as fate it is enough to
know the characters to guess the ends
the drama scenario concerns callimachus
desire to bed Lucrezia the beautiful
young wife of a doddering fool
masquerading as a doctor a kalamaki
advises the husband Nakia to administer
a potion of Mandrake - Lucretia to
render her fertile he also warns that
the drug could have fatal implications
for the first man to have intercourse
with her he slyly suggests to nikkyo
that a dupe be found for this purpose
persuaded by her confessor a knavish
cleric to comply with her husband's
wishes the virtuous
Krysia at last allows Callum Accio into
her bed where he has no difficulty
convincing her to accept him as her
lover on a more permanent basis sales of
this sort were already commonplace
throughout Europe by the Middle Ages
though critics have remarked that
Machiavelli lent freshness to even this
hackneyed material Sydney Anglo has
commended his clear crisper repartee and
his ability to nod jaw ribs at
improprieties and double meanings
despite characterization that his
rudimentary haphazard and inconsistent
with even protagonists going through
their motions like automata Macaulay on
the other hand has applauded the players
correct and vigorous delineation of
human nature
they decided influence on the
philosophies of Thomas Hobbes and Sir
Francis Bacon and on the thought of such
modern political theorists Seussville
fraida Pareto Machiavelli has been
called the founder of empirical
political science primarily on the
strength of the discourses and the
prints taken in historical perspective
it is understandable that the prince
should have dwarfed Machiavelli's other
works for with this slim treatise the
author confronted the ramifications of
power when its procurement and exercise
when notably preemptory commentators
have come to weigh the integrity of
Machiavelli's controversial fought
against the pressing political
conditions which formed it some like
Roberto Ridolfi have endeavoured through
their studies to dislodge the
long-standing perception of Machiavelli
as a ruthless character stating in
judging Machiavelli one must take
account of his anguish despair of virtue
and his tragic sense of evil on the
basis of sentences taken out of context
and of outward appearances he was judged
a cold and cynical man a sneer at
religion and virtue but in fact there is
hardly a page of his writing and
certainly no action of life that does
not show him to be passionate generous
ardent and basically religious Peter
bonds and Ella has stated in European
writers Machiavelli created a new
religion out of politics with all its
faithful implications for modern
intellectual history
in 1502 Machiavelli married marietta
Cassini the couple had six children
together four sons and two daughters
niccolò machiavelli the prince is one of
the most celebrated and notorious books
in the history of Western political
thought most celebrated and notorious
books in the history of Western
political thought it continues to
influence discussions of war and peace
the nature of politics and the relation
of private ethics to public duties
ostensibly a 16th century manual of
instruction on certain aspects of
princely rule and behavior the Prince
anticipates and complicates modern
political and philosophical questions
what is the right order of society can
Western politics still be the model for
progress toward peace and prosperity or
does our freedom to create our
individual purposes and pursuits
undermine our public responsibilities
are the characters of our politics
markedly different for better or for
worse than the politics of earlier eras
Machiavelli argues that there is no
ideal transcendent order to which one
can conform and that the right order is
merely the one that has the capacity to
persist over time the princes emphasis
on the importance of an effective truth
over any abstract ideal marks it as one
of the first works of modern political
philosophy so I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographic if you did
there's a couple of things you could do
right now one is hit that like button
below also if you want more stuff like
this we put out brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday so hit that
subscribe button below and subscribe
button doesn't do what it used to on
YouTube if you actually want to get a
notification about these videos please
do hit that Bell button next to the
subscribe button and that'll send you a
notification every time every Monday and
Thursday won't put out a new video also
if you want to watch something else
right now stuff from the archive over
there on the right and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]